Germany this story is actually kind of
inspiring I think according to the
Anholt goofed nations brand index and
I'm pretty sure I pronounced that wrong
yeah sure Germany is now the world's
favorite country now of course Germany's
had some problems remember World War two
Nazis all that they've had a bad rep for
a long time and there's still the butt
of jokes often but this does kind of
show that things can change so let's
take a look at the top ten countries
Germany is number one the United States
number two we've slipped we're not
number one anymore we'll get to that in
a moment
UK number three France Canada Japan
Italy Switzerland Australia Sweden so
none of those two seem that surprising
to me because those are sort of all the
westernized countries with good civil
rights and human rights and things of
that nature and as it says on the right
side the USA which held first place
since 2009 and is still seen as number
one in creativity contemporary culture
and educational institutions suffered
from its perceived shaky record in
global peace and security that certainly
makes sense with everything going on in
the world right now by the way it's not
the Gulf nations brand index is the GfK
I'd like my guy didn't put it in
capitals and by the way to prove a point
about our earlier segment on CNN and
correction see I screwed up and then I
corrected it within 30 seconds that's
you that's professional people thank you
thank you thank you
all right so the reason I like this
story is because this shows that people
and countries can change and I really
like this Germany has done some horrible
horrible stuff and yet they've changed
and modernized and blah blah blah you've
got something I can see that glimmer in
your eye okay so how long does it take
to forget a genocide alright cool that's
that's that's the statute I think say
roughly 60 probably 65 years yeah my
knee-jerk reaction for just a bevy of
reasons it was you've gotta be kidding
me yeah but once I got over myself and
and got over my initial emotional
reaction which I think in you know being
Jewish being American and being a human
but we're entitled to
I thought okay what have they done to
deserve this what have they done to
deserve to take this number-one spot and
I'm not exactly a this is gonna shock
buzz you're not really a global policy
expert your guy messed up yeah but what
I do what I do understand what I do
believe to be true I think about Germany
is they have really gone above and
beyond when it comes to reparations yeah
and when it comes to the policies
they've changed when they you literally
you cannot own a copy of mine comp is my
understanding yeah
you know they've the the reparations
they've made to families that were
affected by the Holocaust and that is
that is a stand-up thing to do as a
nation yeah so I'd like to think that
that has something to do with it
obviously the atrocities are going to
haunt people for centuries and it's it's
a horrible thing and it can't be erased
and it shouldn't be erased but the
things that their country and their
government has done to start to
apologize and to start to heal that
nation and heal so many people I think
it's commendable so to that point 65
years or whatever it is I'd my math
isn't perfect but it's pretty good right
like that's actually if you think about
how a nation can change and go from that
to number one in the world popularity
contest I mean that's pretty good like
it helps that the rest of Europe doesn't
have its [ __ ] together yeah that's all
just getting a line and handle what's
right with the world right you know so
you think they maybe stuff the ballot
box because they're so organized I mean
that's the thing is like yeah just this
is what happens when you apply your
talents in the right direction all
they're systematizing when it's toward
killing Jewish people like that's not
where you should be putting your ability
it's a lot of wasted energy yeah your
talents you guys feel about the USA not
being number one on a list we like to be
liked everybody loves us and they hate
us all the time you know when there's a
comment card after a customer service
and you want to give them a five cuz hey
it's fun but you give before cuz there's
always room for improvement yeah keep
them humble that's what I say so that's
what they're doing that's what the rest
world is saying we need you you know
like Isis no one else is gonna ever do
anything about it so we're gonna hate
you if you're there and we're gonna hate
if you're not there but we still need
you United second place isn't nothing
but I'm an achiever so America will
always root for the underdog we also
like to be the top dog and the underdog
what's your favorite country putting you
on the spot right now
no alene time if you had to pick a
country not the United States let's just
let's just throw Unites States out for
the purposes of this if you had to pick
another country that you really dig like
I said a great whirlwind summer in the
Greek island so I could I could live up
my days they found they found democracy
great feta cheese for me I'm gonna go
with my favorite country being I really
enjoyed going to Italy recently so it's
like fresh and they barely cook their
meat so that's awesome
yeah the pastas fresh what do you like
I'm gonna say Canada because they have
they yeah because they basically do the
right thing in the world they don't get
overreached and over-involved they stand
up for the right principles they have to
deal with us living right below them and
also they have to deal with that threat
that every right winger makes constantly
which is that I'm gonna move up to
Canada and they have to deal with that
and that's that's not fun and then and
yet they always are smiling they're very
pleasant every time I've been there
great finally people I thought you were
just gonna basically saying I like cold
America yeah well right weather-wise
it's not perfect for me I don't like our
southern yeah it's like I don't like
coke but I'll have like you know Safeway
select soda
the Mediterranean is out